قام الاتحاد والعام التونسي للشغل بسلسله
من الحركات الاحتجاجيه ضد الحكومه وسياسات
الرئيس قيس السعيد بعدما كان مؤيدا في
البدايه لاجراءات الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو تموز عام 2021 في السادس عشر من
يونيو حزيران في العام التالي نظم اضرابا
عاما للاحتجاج على ترد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
ورفض الحكومه اقرار زياده في رواتب
الموظفين في اواخر السنه الماضيه اعلن
الاتحاد انه سينظم احتجاجات حاسده ويحتل
الشوارع لاظهار رفضه ميزانيه التقشف لعام
2023 ما لبث اتحاد الشغل ان استهل السنه
الجديده بعد ذلك باضراب للعاملين في شركه
ترامب والحافلات الرئيسيه من اجل مطالب
اجتماعيه ثم اتبعه في اواخر شهر يناير
كانون الثاني باضراب لعمال النقل الجوي
والبري والبحري استمر يومين احتجاجا على
ما وصفه بتهميش الحكومه للشركات العامه
في الثامن عشر من الشهر التالي فبراير
شباط نظم الاف العمال احتجاجات في عدد من
الولايات التونسيه للتنديد بترد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه واحتجاجا على ما
وصفت باعتداءات السلطه على الحريات
والحقوق النقابيه ثم جاء احتجاج اليوم
الرابع من مارس اذار في ختام سلسله من
التجمعات العماليه في انحاء البلاد
احتجاجا على سياسات السلطه والاوضاع
الاجتماعيه